We have a quick update on Benidorm Fest 2024
before the submission closes.
First up, we have another date for our
Eurovision national final calendar
because we now know that the final of Benidorm Fest
will take place on February 3rd.
And before that,
the two semi finals will take place on January 30th
and February 1st
respectively.
In addition to this,
it has also been revealed that the lucky participants
will be competing in next year's competition.
Will be revealed on November 11th in Seville
during the Latin Grammy Awards.
Are you excited for Benidorm Fest 2024?
Who would you like to see
compete in next year's competition?
Let us know in the comments.